[Applause]
90 is contributed the people that will
be in theaters September 21st Michael
Moore
Michael Moore what you do with a
standing ovation
alright that's every time I see somebody
tell me you had a Hail Mary solution to
this Supreme Court pick you think it's
not a done deal well I don't think we
should give up on the fact listen the
Senate right now is 5149 right sadly
McCain will not be able to vote so it's
a 50:49 vote right come on yeah but mine
I know we have to write we've got to
push it off till after November and I
don't trust every Democrat and know the
we have to hold the Democratic seats we
have but look 90% of incumbents are
always returned I mean so that that
should we should the Democrats in
Montana North Dakota West West Virginia
they've got to do their job they'll do
their job our job is to win Nevada
Arizona and Tennessee and they can all
be won if the votes gonna take place
before that the safe no no no the idea
is though they first we first have to
find ways to stop that will from hide
ways what what does that mean well I'll
I'll join a million other people
surrounding the United States Capitol
[Applause]
let me tell you something this judge
goes through for the rest of at least
while all of our lives it's a right no
no court that's it it's over
combined with the White House and the
Congress dollars well yes and if this is
the last American president
so and
the senator from Maine worked with what
the people in Nevada they've got a
incredible democratic congresswoman
who's running for Senate they are I've
already voted for they love her Arizona
an incredible democratic congresswoman
already elected by the people of Arizona
running with where they've got two
Republican senators who want to stop
Trump McCain and then you've got the
beloved Democratic governor in tennis
this depends on us who's
running and for the Seneca why can't we
do this because they because the
Republicans control the Senate and Mitch
McConnell's gonna call a vote before
they know and then she's gonna call them
all they said only what are we gonna
know it can't you know they don't think
like that they don't think there's no
magical syncing and they go fertilized
egg is a human being yeah they've got
millions behind them when are we gonna
start talking like that talking is well
we have to put the same pressure on on
Murkowski and collins connected to the
health care issue which was politically
inspired today what are you doing on the
Handmaid's Tale you already scared the
[ __ ] out of us can I can I just don't
look get a plug for The Handmaid's Tale
this is HBO [ __ ] screaming
yeah yeah great watch the show you don't
watch the show you should only watch HBO
oh where my special is on a week okay so
we just lost the court that's not what's
a little bit serious but here can I just
make a serious point yes in The
Handmaid's Tale okay let me just tell
you this this is a serious point the
best part of the show are the flashbacks
where she tries to figure out where was
the point when it was too late
right where was it when look at it where
was the point where if we'd all just
risen up right if we just done something
but because it happens in little that's
right that's how fast is it how fascism
were they do it in the middle and listen
we have a president lose one normal week
we have a president who by the way was
not elected by the people and constantly
refers to himself yeah constantly you
know you're referring to himself in the
Third Reich
no you and I were on this page before
anybody else that he was serious about
running and that he absolutely could one
and probably would for maybe the maybe
they won't listen to us now well they
didn't listen before and not going and
that no but seriously they have to
listen they have to they you people
where are you you you have to listen
this time because because he is going to
win the 2020 election even if he doesn't
he's not going to leave and he's not
that's well I don't that what you have
to understand the second term if he
doesn't have to nobody stops him this
man believes in being president for life
yes he said a few weeks ago Roosevelt
got four terms why can't I yes but down
the hole he loves president gee
president Wilkins containers Bay he
loves the dictators and I'm telling you
I'm telling you my friends if we don't
stop it now you'll look back at the show
where we were all goofing around talking
about The Handmaid's Tale but this this
is the moment the moment that though
that he said that he was going to
appoint someone to the Supreme Court and
we know this is the person that you said
earlier what's your movie about we're
not gonna plug anything here what are
you talking about we talk about his
pocket Joe for five minutes yes I'm I'm
finishing my movie and getting it out
before the midterms because I want
millions of people to get to the polls
[Music]
[Applause]